read my lips no new taxes grover
norquist stops by to discuss how you
don't even realize all the money that
you're making thanks to the Trump
administration and then Grover spills
the beans on an incredible piece of
executive action that may make you even
more money this is all good news after
that with conservatives like Tommy
Lauren who needs leftists we will
finally have to analyze Tommy's very
unfortunate comments on television but
to make us all feel better again daily
wire to sports correspondent Jeremy the
god-king boring stops by for a world cup
Update I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
there is so much going on today I don't
even know where to begin
obviously the Trump judicial nominee the
Supreme Court nominee has not quite come
out yet we're hearing little rumors I
don't want a report on it quite yet but
we'll have a lot more on that tomorrow
some other great news I am going on tour
I'm coming to a college near you there's
a time and a place for everything and
that place is College that's right I'm
teaming up with EF yaf young America's
Foundation to go on a college tour this
fall it's gonna be a lot of fun you can
check out they just did a story on it at
yeah org you can read all about the tour
it's going to be called cough FA on
campus we're gonna be addressing the
really the eternal questions politics
religion how to be a man when you look
like a Maddow what how to sell how to
not write anything and sell 100,000
copies and we were we are going to
analyze on this tour once and for all
what cough FA really means if you want
your college to be a part of that tour
go to YF dot org and put in a request
ASAP I'd really put it in quickly
because there there are only going to be
limited engagements and we're gonna
start looking at that list really soon
so go to YF dot org and put in a request
ASAP if you want cough FA on your campus
this fall and again it is time to join
the conversation on Tuesday July 17th at
5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific
Andrew Klavan the Supreme Lord of the
multiverse himself will answer your
questions moderated by the beautiful and
dauntless Alicia Krause the QA will
stream live on YouTube and Facebook for
everyone to watch only daily wire
subscribers can ask drew questions to
submit your questions log into daily
wire comm head over to the conversation
page to watch the live stream type your
question into the daily wire chat box
have it read and answered on the air but
you can only do that if you're a
subscriber subscribe to get your
questions answered by Andrew Klavan
Supreme Lord of the multiverse Tuesday
July 17th at 5:30 Eastern 2:30 Pacific
and join the conversation we got to get
to this world cup update before we do
that it's summertime and that means two
things one it means I need to make a
little money honey so we got to thank a
wonderful sponsor it also means the
Flies are coming back and I can speak to
this very personally because I live in
Southern California
and because Southern California is one
of the
centers of evil in the modern world
there are a lot of flies you know the
Lord doesn't always paint with a subtle
brush so I thank goodness for dynatrap
Dyna traps indoor fly light is the only
effective solution to indoor flies I
have ever seen
I use these constantly I'm probably
bankrupting the company because they
give me a freebie to try and then I just
took like four or five of them put them
all over my apartment they are so so
good
we have dynatrap is the leading
manufacturer of outdoor mosquito and
insect traps now they've come out with
the indoor fly light it looks really
subtle sometimes when I was in New York
I use fly tape you know which is just
what trash people use you know it just
looks awful you invite people over to
your apartment and it's just oh I'd like
to show you all the flies that I've
decorated my apartment with oh that look
at that cute little bug hanging from my
light don't do that you you get the
indoor fly light it looks really chic
it's a nice metallic look to it the
light is good it also hides all of the
bugs really good I could not recommend
this product more highly I am I am a
customer as well I'm buying more of
these things go to dynatrap calm dy n8 e
ra p comm enter the promo code daily
wired Dai ly w ir e receive 15% off any
of their products let me spell all those
things for you again
dy n8 e ra pd OT c om promo code Dai ly
w ir e lmnopq rst uvwxyz 15% off their
products promo code a lee weyer dynatrap
the safe silent simple solution to
household insect control without further
ado I do want to talk a little bit more
about about what's going on in the news
and about this yaf tour before that I
need an update from the world of sports
for that we turn to our sister network
daily why are two sports correspondent
Jeremy the god-king boring
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yowza
thank you Michael it's great to be back
with you for a segment one YouTube
commenter observed as coming off more
like ignorance than humor that's our
daily wire to coverage of the Fuji Water
World Cup let's get right into the
action or what passes for action and the
sport where the tied game can be
resolved by getting two teams yet
another opportunity to tie that however
is not what happened in our first story
of the week that is host Russia's
humiliating defeat at the hands of their
former socialist protegees Croatia after
a tied match Michael it all came down to
the shootout in which each team was
given five penalty kicks to determine
the winner it's actually the most
eventful and near stimulating moment in
any soccer match which raises an obvious
question since any tie is statistically
indistinguishable from a 0-0 score which
is how every game begins why can't we
just skip the entire deathly dole affair
and go straight to the shootout in every
soccer match of course that would
admittedly make soccer feel like a
completely frivolous non game in which
the winner is essentially determined by
luck which I believe is the answer to
YouTube commenter Mikey 87's question of
the week quote WTF does GD P have to do
with anything , it's a sport exclamation
mark well you're half right Mikey 87 as
Russia found out the hard way by being
unmanned by a nation with roughly 3% of
their gross domestic product also if you
skip the entire match where would you
put the funny commercials oh that's
right
there aren't any funny commercials in
soccer since no human being anywhere on
earth has the kind of willpower and
discipline over there attention span to
actually wait even longer to see what's
going to happen in the next slow-moving
children's game in which not a single
thing has ever happened since that one
guy was hurt ironically while faking an
injury in 1957 also most people for whom
this dreadful exhibition is their only
escape don't have the individual income
to purchase thing in the first place
still the biggest news of the week at
least for Anglophile was England's
defeat of Sweden
both in GDP two trillion to 511 billion
and in gameplay to zero mm-hmm that's
right England has officially made the
semi-finals bringing their number one
best-selling single dream one step
closer to reality it's coming to the
House of course I know that many of our
viewers as proud and patriotic Americans
are wondering why we here at the Daily
wire too haven't devoted a bit more time
to covering America standing in the
current worldwide tournament we too have
been confused as to why we haven't seen
Old Glory waving above more matches
fortunately angry YouTube killjoy morosa
pointed us to the answer with this
edifying comment quote clearly you're
triggered because the u.s. couldn't
qualify against the likes of Panama and
Trinidad and Tobago lol candidly morosa
this sports journalist had no idea as I
liked almost every one of America's
native sons who didn't grow up doing
missionary work in the third world where
being a girl never contemplate never
contemplated this farce of a competition
even one since I was five years old and
learning basic motor functions I am
however certainly triggered now that I
know you mean to tell me that despite
having a GDP equal to 25 percent of the
world's total economy owning the world's
reserve currency having the finest
athletes in the world as evidenced by
almost every metric including having won
more medals than any other country in
the Olympics by double having the
longest enduring constitutional republic
in human history and having almost
single-handedly invented all of the
splendid wonders of modernity and having
kept the free nations of the world
largely safe for more than a
half-century America can't beat a
Caribbean island nation with fewer than
a million and a half people and a GDP
lower than that kid who invented putting
pictures of your food on the internet
for people to like why I dare say one
begins to wonder if this whole soccer
business is even a fair measurement of
human accomplishment at all Michael
yowza really thorough report during I
really appreciate that I was wondering
would you say you spend more time
looking at the YouTube comments on our a
segment or watch
the World Cup yowza terrific well I
can't wait for the next update I do have
to ask as I think are all red-blooded
patriotic Americans how much longer is
this World Cup gonna go on hell if I
know Michael well I gotta tell you I I
sort of hope this World Cup keeps going
on and on because I really these these
segments have really kept me so abreast
I feel like I've learned something in
every single one and I and I hope the
rest of our audience has finally learned
something too
Jeremy German guy king boring everybody
see you next week really they're a stuff
I guess we I'm really glad we finally
started up that sister Network you know
for all of that important sports
coverage that we couldn't get to really
great so we had grover norquist come by
we're obviously all waiting for the
Supreme Court nomination decision right
now I have noticed that people are just
saying well gossip on Twitter and
everything all of the people in the
Trump coalition who really matter to to
the Trump coalition from a wide variety
of places in it movement conservatives
Republicans officeholders grassroots
activists all this they all seem to be
pushing for a me koni Barrett though
it's unclear right now who it's gonna be
we'll talk about that a little at the
end what Trump has to gain or lose from
the possible nominees I also I'm gonna
take on Tommy Lehren and kill you know
it kills me I try to be so nice to
people and I don't want to like destroy
so-and-so or destroy whatever like be
mean to people within the broad tent of
the right-wing
Tommy Lauren has just gone too far and
she's slandered pro-life conservatives
one too many times
and she's really pouting destructive
nonsense
so we're gonna we're gonna cover that at
the very end before we get to Grover I
got a I got to make a little more money
honey hit listen I mean this though
Grover is gonna explain to us why we're
all even richer than we think we are I I
am I'm giving you something right now
I'm about to make I'm gonna personally
make you richer by telling you about
Mint Mobil mint Mobil is the solution to
cellphones you know this you sign up for
some cell phone plan and then you think
you're paying one
and you end up somehow your your bill
always comes in the mail it's just
gigantic and you think why am i paying
100 $200 a month for cell phone service
the big in big Wireless stands for a lot
of things big contracts big bills big
secrets what companies like AT&T and
Verizon don't want you to know is
there's a way to cut down your wireless
bill to just 15 bucks a month that is no
joke $15 a month your bill comes it's 15
bucks a month
mint mobile you won't have to sacrifice
service you won't have to sacrifice
anything
mint Mobile is the game-changing company
that's taken everything wrong with big
Wireless made it right mint Mobile is
proving to millions of Americans that
getting your wireless bill doesn't have
to be the worst day of the month you can
keep your old number you can keep all of
your existing contracts you can choose
between 2 5 or 10 gigabyte 4G LTE plans
the the big secret here one of the
reasons that cell phone companies are
able to charge you an arm and a leg is
because they are way over charging you
for data
so you'll see maybe you've signed up for
an unlimited data plane you say oh good
I've got unlimited and I'm paying a
zillion dollars for it but I have
unlimited but moat the average American
uses 5 gigabytes of data a month they
don't use any of it it's like you know
you're paying for you go to dinner or
you want you want to get like a quick
little dinner with your wife and they
say hey so you can either get that that
nice dinner over there or you can spend
$4,000 and have an unlimited supply of
hamburgers so okay well unlimited
unlimited hamburger sounds good I don't
know if I should spend $4,000 right that
you don't want to overpay for data that
you're not using every plane comes with
unlimited talk and text you and safely
annoy your friends and loved ones if
you're not 100% satisfied mint mobile
has you covered with a 7 day money-back
guarantee you try it out if on that
sixth day you know at the 11:59 at night
or whatever you can get all your money
back for that try it out Fox your old
wireless bill and start saving with mint
mobile to get your new wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month plus free shipping
on your mobile SIM card which is so easy
to install you just get the card pop it
in they'll give you a little tool for
but you can use a paperclip pop it in
pop it out it takes you two seconds it's
really easy I've seen it I've done it
it's very simple to do Mint mobile.com
/co ff8 co v fe fe mint MI Mt
mobile mo bi le dot com slash cough fa
COV fe fe cut your wireless bill to
fifteen bucks a month get free shipping
on your mint Mobile SIM card mint mobile
comm slash cough fa without further ado
we had one of the key figures of the
conservative movement for the last 50
years grover norquist he's the head of
americans for tax reform he was the head
of the college Republican National
Committee when he was a young man I
believe it was President Reagan who
asked him to start Americans for Tax
Reform he has been a conservative leader
to keep the Republican Party to the
right to keep our taxes low to stop the
government from taking away our freedom
and our property he stopped by to talk
about what's really going on in the
Trump tax plan what it means for the
rest of us what president Trump's
administration can do and might be doing
to give you even more disposable income
and where he sees the conservative
movement going without further ado
here's my interview with Robert Norquist
Grover thank you for being here yes so I
look around right now I see a
deregulation government on the way to
being able to drown itself in a bathtub
I see major tax reform Grover thank you
for being here yes so I look around
right now I see a deregulation
government on the way to being able to
drown itself in a bathtub
I see major tax reform I see a movement
for smaller government I see more
originalist saan the court who are
willing to rein in an expanse of
government are you ready to declare
victory I'm we're moving in the right
direction we have a long way to go
because the other team took a hundred
years to mess it up half of the federal
government was created in four years
between 34 and 36 the New Deal a bunch
of entitlements and between 64 and 66
that's 10% of GDP absorbed by government
programs created in four years only but
to get there they had to get a
supermajority pass it back off and lose
the next set of elections and then keep
going with some steady upward movement
largely because of their entitlements so
we
a long way to go but we are heading in
the right direction on several parallel
paths as you say regulation taxes even
on spending I mean with that we're gonna
make sure we're making some progress
absolutely it's it's a difficult to keep
in mind how much ground we lost during
the Obama administration and this was
such the argument in 2016 you say guys
you know we have careened off of this
cliff we need to do anything we can to
pull it back in the right direction on
tax reform which a lot of President
Trump's critics said that's never going
to get through they're not gonna be able
to pass it he's able to get it through
in his first year does tax reform mean a
better PR strategist it seems like this
should be much more popular than it is
it's a tax cut for virtually all
Americans and when you factor in the
corporate tax cut it is a tax cut for
all Americans but why is it not more
popular there are two challenges the
first is that today 83% of Americans
have direct deposit for their paychecks
I don't see my paycheck it goes straight
to the bank I couldn't I can't tell you
how much of a tax cut I got because I
don't look at that difference and so
quite a number of Americans have not
looked and seen that every two weeks
every month
they've got more being put into their
bank accounts than last year the IRS
calculates the more than ninety percent
of Americans have a significant cut in
their taxes which means an increase in
their pay because one of things we need
to say over and over again is a tax cut
is a pay increase for taxpayers a tax
cut is a pay increase for tax payers and
ninety percent of Americans got that pay
increase in May there was a jump in
consumer spending there's some
economists think that people actually
looked at their bank account and said
hey there's more than we thought and
they didn't notice that every two weeks
but they did notice that May and you saw
spending
moved upward the other challenges we
made fundamental changes in the economy
that would be benefitting us for the
next hundred years with more investment
in the United States 300 billion dollars
flowed back in in the first three months
of this year three hundred five billion
dollars 1.7 billion expected over a two
year period
translates into higher wages the
economists say between four or five
thousand dollars for somebody making
between fifty and seventy thousand
dollars you that doesn't happen tomorrow
but it goes up and it lasts the rest of
your life in terms of that increased
sustainable pay increase because if more
capital here in the United States that's
a great point and when you talk about
rearranging certain institutions and
certain structures in the United States
for longer-term investment for
longer-term prosperity the tariffs have
been in the news a lot lately President
Trump is threatening these tariffs with
people who are ripping us off with the
World Trade Organization would say is
playing unfairly well what are the risks
what are the rewards of this tariff
fight and how do you think it's going to
play out well Trump is right on two big
points that we have agreed to tack two
tariffs kills two free trade agreements
that are less advantageous the United
States then they should have been this
is after World War two we felt sorry for
everybody they were all flat and we were
still doing reasonably well and we gave
away more than we needed to over time
both to Japan and to Germany the people
who then question that our allies in
Europe those need to be readjusted and
just as the fact that Europeans don't
pay enough for their defense on NATO we
pay more than they do and it's their
neighborhood we're defending right we're
not working
the Canadians whacking us well not since
1812 anyway so we do have to rethink
some of this in Trump is completely
right and Europeans go nuts because
they've been on a free ride for a long
time and I said some of our trans he's
right about that
second point is that he wants to get to
a more open and freer trading agreement
not to have permanent walls or barriers
or protectionism that's not what he's
argued for he is threatening tariffs in
order to get their attention to reduce
tariff barriers and some of the
agreements that seemed to be coming will
do exactly that the danger that his
goals are good and important the danger
is that when you're playing this game of
fighting with tariffs you're not in
charge of both sides of this the Chinese
can decide maybe they like certain
tariffs and
they can take a lot more pain because
they don't have elections in November
and we do so a trade war that goes on as
opposed to a conflict and argument and
trying to come to a better agreement
well it's even be better for the
Europeans and there are other trading
partners over time I think there is that
danger that spins out of control and we
had enough with the Hatfields and McCoys
nobody can remember who was punching who
why but we keep punching each other that
is a danger it's happened before but I
do think that would the people around
Trump and Trump himself they understand
that the goal is more open trade because
we win that hmm but also need to keep
our taxes low
we were handicapping ourselves when we
had a 35% corporate rate and Communist
China 25% were at 35 does that make any
sense at all we shoot ourselves but with
it with trade and they will yell at the
Chinese because that's their fault no
that was stupid things our government
did to us our trial lawyer laws our tort
laws are destructive no other countries
goofy as our tort laws are we need to
reform that and our regulatory rules are
much more damaging to us than any other
country does to themselves so some of
the stuff we can just stop eating our
own head against the wall that's helpful
and the other we need to tell the
Europeans and the Japanese and the
Chinese we need to get better agreements
the president's committed to that we get
that in the next couple of months I
think you'll see the stock market shoot
through the roof going into November
because it's a little bit slower than it
could be the tax cuts done very well but
there's a concern that tariffs could
escalate okay you could ask him I could
wipe out some of those gains and it is
such a great point a lot of those trade
deals negotiated after World War 2 you
think now we're seventy years on we
don't need to keep you know doling out
the charity here and same thing with
NATO
I wonder looking forward at the election
what can president from point two
booming economy record high employment
tax cut for virtually all Americans on
and on and on
affairs in a more stable place the
regulatory regime you flashed with I'm
sorry no war no war that's what I mean
we could be here all day naming the
concrete policy achievements of the
administration and so what the left rows
out is allegations of racism were Nazism
or he's a mean person and he's a sexist
or whatever how do you think that will
play you've been in Republican politics
a long time how do you think that plays
in November historically speaking
probably Republicans should lose the
house how do you see things shaking out
yeah I think the Senate looks very good
because the playing field because of the
quality of the candidates we got we're
not running anymore Moore's in Alabama
running top quality candidate Lewis
Alabama how do you lose Alabama it's
unbelievable yes that was it was not
helpful and had we gotten that there are
a number of things we could have
accomplished this year that we just
weren't able to that we will be able to
do next year now I'm a little less
worried about the house than some people
because when they say the average over
the last ten elections is to lose 30 the
reason that's the average is that when
Clinton raised taxes he lost 60 when
Obama taxes he lost 60 you average those
were the two Bush years where they
didn't really lose much at all and
gained a little bit 60 and 0 average to
30 but our guy Trump and the Republican
House the Senate didn't raise taxes
didn't explode new government programs
and so I'm I'm not sure that there's
some sort of rule about 30 it's a
historical accident but I think it is if
you raise taxes and throwing massive
your spending programs you lose a lot of
House seats so we do have to worry the
other teams very energized they see
their whole future evaporating in front
of them they see a Supreme Court that no
longer drags the country to the left
every three months with some new large I
mean they think we're gonna go whack
back the other way if we just got a
Supreme Court which held things steady
and left the House and the Senate and
American people make decisions we
wouldn't be dragged leftward ever
leftward and there are some decisions on
questions like racial quotas and
property rights and how much power the
bureaucrats have
Chevron deference and other issues like
that where I think we will see science
that will shift as we did with the Janis
case which says five million people
who've been forced to pay union dues
even though they didn't want to are in
the Union you have to do that anymore
that's huge
that's a tremendous step forward towards
liberty and as side benefit of defunding
the modern left that is it and that is
the that is the focus I know some people
particularly Trump's critics on the
right they were just arguing over you
know how many how many Republicans can
dance on the head of a pin and of course
the the object here is Liberty and
liberty is increasing the Jana's case is
a good example of that although we do
see even from the the tea party years
onward into this new trump era of
politics a shift in the conversation
from issues like deficits the primacy of
lowering taxes increasing economic
Liberty there is a bit of a shift into
cultural issues we're talking you know
Andrew Breitbart was fond of saying
politics is downstream of culture now
there are these larger cultural issues
do you see that trend moving even more
in that direction do you see that as
opposed to the economic agenda or do
they work in tandem
well the establishment press I don't
know why people call the mainstream
press they don't nobody watches I think
I get more viewers than MSNBC I'm on the
internet but but the establishment press
the three networks and PBS and stuff
like that they find culture both issues
left-of-centre cultural issues endlessly
fascinating because you can talk about
them without knowing anything right and
you can also talk about them without any
numbers involved to get in the way of
your theory whereas if you want to talk
about spending and taxes and growth we
do have some numbers that the kind of
hard reality did to bounce up again
we're about Iran expanding Liberty I
think cultures downstream of politics in
the sense that if you give people more
Liberty we now have Chilean people
homeschooling thirty years ago only two
states allowed homeschooling we changed
the law to allow concealed carry permits
in more than forty states there's
seventeen and a half million Americans
with concealed carry permits that
changed the nature of the second
amendment debate more than anything else
not hunting hunting's been fairly stable
declining even but people with concealed
carry permits feeling comfortable
carrying to defend themselves and their
families had changed the culture and
with the decline in Union Union power
meaning power over workers workers are
more free to vote the way they want to
instead of how they're told to Pence
Trump and the Republicans carrying Ohio
in Michigan and Wisconsin and Indiana
and Iowa all have a unionized States
that years ago the unions would have
driven the vote and the politics in
those states with tourist union dues now
we have right to work in Michigan in
Iowa they passed act 10 like they did in
Wisconsin saying no more stolen money
and politics you know I'm not opposed to
money in politics as opposed to stolen
money in politics right that's a great
point and when you give people Liberty
they will react it is funny you can
picture to people bickering over
politics and this and that and but then
when you present them with the reality
of prosperity the reality of
deregulation the reality of just being
more free to say what you want to say
and do what you want to do and spend
your money the way you want to spend
your money raise your kids the way you
want to raise your kids
a lot of that goes away there's an
entire generation now my generation that
grew up with really only foggy memories
of economic prosperity and I think the
reality of that is really finally
setting in I have to hearken back
because you're so famous for Americans
for Tax Reform being this central force
and conservative politics for decades
you also were the executive director of
the college Republican National
Committee now having spent some time
with the college Republicans I go to
campuses and speak a fair bit do you see
any shift there have you paid attention
to what's going on on the campuses
obviously the universities themselves
have imploded because of leftist tyranny
basically but what's going on with the
conservative movement as it as it takes
place on university campuses well I was
in college 74 to 78 and we were coming
right out at the 60s I was at Harvard
where the left took over buildings and
trash stuff so the idea that that
conservatives today or put upon strikes
me is this is not completely do this has
happened before they were blowing up
things in the sixties and seventies with
bombs and killing people so the left on
campus the Weathermen and so on the
Black Panthers these were serious deadly
serious political structures and now you
know they try and Mao Mao people but
even I think one of the advantages the
right had coming out of the seventies
was the boy named Sue phenomenon which
is to be a liberal all my left-wing
friends at the Harvard Crimson student
newspaper was me and a bunch of
Bolsheviks and they would say things
like well you know the death marches in
in Cambodia
they're bringing people into rural
health clinics that's what they would
say what's going on everything oh that's
very nice that they're moving people
into rural health clinics is hundreds of
thousands died and were murdered but
don't would have challenged them mmm but
if I say I think property rights are
important you'd get twenty question well
what if you're on an island and there's
only one you know the well and you own
the you really had to be on the top of
your game to be involved in politics the
Dartmouth review crowd yeah and at
Dartmouth University they put out a
feisty well written free-market
conservative publication and they got
hit all the time they really had to
learn to defend themselves and a lot of
talent came out of the campuses because
they were oppressed because they were
asked 50 questions defend herself defend
yourself defend you and the left guys
like Gore could go around going I
invented the internet and nobody said
excuse me
yeah come again yeah question and now
they're even more lackadaisical on the
left they have a couple of magic words
they say diversity and they're supposed
to have won the argument
whatever that is right like well know it
now it's really the boy named Sue
phenomenon where you just have to call
boys sue that's their that's the next
thing you say okay we can't question
this okay a challenge but but I think
our guys are tougher
coming out at campus because of that yet
will be again you were totally right I I
can attest to this just from my own
brief experience you know there there
was when I was in college they the
lefties had their occupied New Haven
protests and they weren't going and
taking over I'm sorry Liz and I you know
I was a New Haven for four years then I
you stopped occupying I got out of there
basically right afterward but these
people they come in and they just occupy
they didn't take over
Willard hall and you know with machine
guns or something they just sort of sat
around like boring hippies and but for
the ten of us or so on campus who were
conservatives they there were all of
these jobs you were constantly having to
defend your thoughts and this was really
good because you you actually did change
your thoughts it's why I recommend to
people who write in and say should I you
know should I never send my kid to any
left-wing institution I said no send him
to some crazy left-wing school as long
as he can defend his thoughts it'll
either it'll ruin him or it will make
him actually understand what he thinks
and think through his own conservative
thought they had at Yale they had the
buckley program free speech gala a few
years ago and they had Yale students
spitting on the attendees they said how
dare you want to have free speech and
consider other ideas I mean that's
that's really the education that the
left gets on campus the right has so
much more opportunity I'll just I want
to leave on this one question where do
you see it going you know from the
campuses all the way up through the
white house what is next for the
conservative movement you've been you've
been at the center of it for so long
where are we headed
sure the next big win is this Supreme
Court appointment which will give us a
5-4 control that really will rein in
some of the abusive drift to the left
and that has nothing to do with
President Trump right that's what my
Trump critic friends on the right I had
nothing to do with from from one romney
forgot to just let it out of his mind
but it so i should have one yeah darn
there is there is virtue in winning and
also again he put together that list
this is you know
the idea that somehow this key put
together a list he said hold me to this
this is what I'm going to do better than
what then either Bush did better than
what Reagan had frankly now he had over
time a conservative movement around and
it made that a lot easier he had a
Republican House and Senate that made it
easier but that still didn't get Romney
or McCain across the finish line and we
we lived across the finish line price
with with Bush so Trump brought
something to the table by winning and he
is governed in a way that expands
Liberty through the courts he's focused
on the courts alone with Mitch McConnell
the two of them are working that very
very well they keep cleaning more and
more of those seats the I understand
will have 20 to 25% of the circuit court
seats by December Wow all people so this
is very helpful keep the Senate we can
keep that going the next big apple to
drop the next big thing to happen is
that there is a movement for the
Treasury Secretary to change that said
by the definition of cost when you
calculate capital gains is not cost what
you paid for land or a building or stock
but cause plus inflation so it takes
flash and out of capital gains about
half of capital gains is inflation when
you sell a home a building land stock
your grandmother's owned for 50 years
writing it will drop in effect drop the
capital gains tax in half and
tremendously strengthen the economy you
can do this by not executive order but
my definitional change by regulatory
change the secretary minuchin of the
Treasury said that if Congress doesn't
do it he may many of the people half the
cabinet I've talked to his for it the
entire leadership House and Senate
supports it hasn't gotten a lot of
attention although the Wall Street
Journal did a piece where minuchin said
you'd be good for the economy and if
Congress doesn't act I may okay so I
think that will happen in the next two
months I think you see the stock market
begin to go way up very strong every
house all land all stock would all be
worth more because it's a hedge against
inflation honored
raishin rather than being attacks on
inflation which makes selling an old
house or an old you know land or
buildings more expensive than it should
be so that should be a tremendous
liberalization of the economy I Grover I
have got to have you back more often I
feel so good by the end of because this
is I was already feeling good with the
way the country is going but there's a
lot of light on the horizon and that we
can just look forward to it grover
norquist thank you so much for being
here
good to be with you take it easy man I
got to bring them back all day long
we don't have the great news yet we're
gonna see III I'm waiting on the Supreme
Court pic to see if Trump just trolls
everybody in pics Merrick garland like
ha ha I got you you know T he and then
we've gone to the next one I've got so
much more to talk about we got to talk
about Tommy Lauren I've held my tongue
too long on her and another another
little laugh we can all have together
before the SCOTUS pic but if you're on
Facebook or YouTube I'm sorry you got to
go to daily wire.com to see the rest of
the show it's ten bucks a month $100 for
an annual membership you will get me the
Andrew Clavin show the ben shapiro show
ask questions in the conversation ask
questions in the mailbag none of that
matters because unless President Trump
nominates Merrick garland for the
Supreme Court which I don't think Vegas
is putting a lot of money on right now
then tomorrow morning Oh tomorrow
morning most likely we hope knock on
wood you'll be able to just it's it's
eat right now even it's too much just
all that all of the op-eds leading up to
the decision make sure you get your
leftist your tumblr you need it we'll be
right back go to daily wire.com
Tommi Lauren
Oh Tommy Lauren look you know me I don't
like to be mean to people I don't even
like to be mean to lefties I definitely
don't like to be mean to people who were
ostensibly in the conservative coalition
or a sort of right-wing or conservative
or whatever that is why by the way when
Tommy Lauren last year went on the view
and called pro-life conservatives a
hypocrites slandered pro-life
conservatives I held my tongue because I
actually sort of feel bad for her she
got very famous when she was very young
and very ignorant and I wanted to give
her a free pass and so she could like
read a book or something and then stop
spouting this sort of nonsense
then last night at the most crucial
moment as President Trump looks to fill
a Supreme Court seat a generational
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to
restore American liberty and
constitutional jurisprudence
Tommy Lauren goes on television in
spouts this incoherent destructive
blather here it is I'm gonna say
something my fellow conservatives and
Trump supporters may not like but I must
be true to my beliefs whatever the party
line so it's time for final thoughts
pressing for a Supreme Court decision to
overturn roe v-- wade would be a huge
mistake yes the new High Court vacancy
is a huge opportunity for conservative
values and principles I get it and I
understand the passion behind the
pro-life movement but to use
conservatives newfound power and pulled
a Challenge decision that according to
new Quinnipiac poll most Americans
support would be a mistake this
president is winning for the American
people on the economy foreign policy and
tax reform these are areas that benefit
all Americans regardless of religion or
social beliefs if we continue to focus
on these things and immigration will
sail into 2020 with all three branches
in our control that's how we get things
done for the American people that's how
we win let's go after sanctuary cities
and push for voter ID laws we lose when
we start tampering with social issues
consider this when Supreme Court justice
Neil gorsh got to his confirmation
hearings with a Senate joushi Airy
committee he was grilled on the
so-called Trump litmus test on abortion
he responded by telling
Lindsey Graham he would have walked out
the door if Trump had asked him to
overturn Roe even if conserve his decide
to go for the roe v-- wade jugular it's
unlikely to succeed legal tradition
makes it harder to overturn a past
decision unless there are strong grounds
for doing so and a departure from
precedent like Roe which has since been
upheld by other cases is even harder to
come by during his hearing Justice
Gorsuch made a point of noting the
decision had already been reaffirmed
several times do we really want to fight
for this alienate Democrats moderates
and libertarians all to lose in the end
anyway that's a risk I don't think it's
worth taking and I'm saying this is
someone who would personally choose life
but also feels it's not the government's
place to dictate this isn't a black and
white issue and I would never judge
anyone in that position I believe the
way to encourage someone to choose life
is to treat her with compassion
understanding and love not government
regulation because let's be honest the
federal government does few things well
and I believe regulating social issues
is an area where it fails let the
churches the nonprofits and the
community groups step in not Almighty
Uncle Sam but those are my final
thoughts feel free to disagree I don't
even know where to begin I don't have it
where do I begin with that I think just
about everything she said was wrong and
just utterly uninformed and an ignorant
of even what the question is so I get
and and the worst part of this is it
where we're at this crucial moment where
they this most important hour and she
uses this opportunity to spout this
destructive nonsense to begin so let's
just let's I don't know let's just jump
in she says look I would personally
choose life but I I would never tell
other people to choose life why why
would you personally choose life is it
because it's a it's a living being is it
because it's a human and you don't want
to kill the human or is what you're
saying basically I would never kill my
beautiful special progeny but all those
poor ethnic minorities they should kill
theirs that's what you're saying when
you say I would personally never choose
life because my baby is like special but
all your little babies kill those baby
we don't
those babies so let's go back to the top
she says that we not just that we
shouldn't be pro-life anymore as
conservatives we shouldn't overturn roe
v wade roe v wade is the worst decision
in the history of the Supreme Court it
is based on absolutely nothing it comes
from a fabricated constitutional right
to abortion based on an earlier
fabricated constitutional general right
to privacy that does not exist the
judges who said that it exists who
invented it said that it doesn't come
from the Constitution it comes from the
penumbra's and emanations of the
penumbral emanating blah blah blah blah
we just want it to exist it's totally
made up so just to begin regardless of
what you think about abortion roe v wade
has to be overturned because it's
anti-constitutional it steals the the
right to decide public policy questions
from where it belongs in the legislature
of with the states with the people and
it steals that for the government if
Tommy's an argument here is that we
shouldn't give undue power to the
government that decision just in and of
itself with without regard to the
question of abortion it gives uh Turley
undue power to the the Constitution in
almost cracks our constitutional system
then afterward the the notion that
running on social issues will hurt
Republicans is simply not true president
from ran on social issues
he ran a vigorously pro-life campaign
she actually references it in this
incoherent segment she says that you
know Gorsuch when he was up for the
court had to answer for president
Trump's policy because in his campaign
President Trump promised I will appoint
justices to overturn roe v wade he won
on that that's what won Tommy not
running away from that so even her her
own evidence for her point actually
utterly undercuts her point and argues
for the opposite of her point also then
to say that we're going to lose future
elections if we talk about abortion
young Americans are the most pro-life
generation in the country it's not that
Americans have gotten more in favor of
abortion over time the American since
roe v-- wade America has moved much more
in the direction of pro-life the country
is about evenly split right now and
actually when you drill down in access
proper questions about when babies
should be allowed to be killed the
country becomes overwhelmingly pro-life
but young Americans Millennials are the
most pro-life generation in the country
so so that
point doesn't make any sense and then
she says we need to win we need to win
win win win so we've already seen that
her strategy wouldn't win right the
winning strategy is the one that we're
doing the pro-life strategy but what is
winning if we say look guys if we just
stop trying to do conservative things
then conservatives will win so that
that's a Pyrrhic victory darling that's
not that isn't a win that's that's a
that's the opposite of a win that's
abdicating responsibility entirely and
it kills me to take shots at people who
call themselves conservative who think
they're conservatives but first of all
this was to do to give this ridiculous
screed on national television
this fact free screed that so crucial an
hour is either utterly reckless and
brain-dead or it's sabotage of the
conservative movement as a Justice is
about to be picked once in a lifetime so
it demands wide sweeping opprobrium but
also look you get second chances but you
don't get endless chances if you're
going to be a national television store
you need to read a book you had like one
book you need to understand at least the
question that you're discussing
regardless of your point on it my
problem isn't that Tommy is apparently a
pro-abortion fanatic so to speak she
takes the sacramental view of abortion
apparently for everybody's babies but
her own it that isn't quite the issue
the issue is she doesn't even understand
the question she has no idea what is at
stake and she's spouting this
destructive inanity on on national
television she's more than welcome Tommy
if you're if you're watching this clip
you're more than welcome to come on the
show and we can talk about this I hope
you do come on the show but one cannot
remain silent when this sort of nonsense
is being spouted by what are apparently
saboteurs in the conservative movement
if you're if you've got conservatives
like this who needs leftists who needs
them that's just a little little fiery
point to end on because it's so so
frustrating when conservatives or
nominal conservatives try to snatch
defeat from the jaws of victory before
we go away I know we're running out of
time but I've just got to turning to the
actual question of the Supreme Court
today and the actual question of who
this nominee is going to be Cabot
Phillips a great great genius
and wonderful a media figure from campus
reform he went out and he asked students
what they thought of president Trump's
nominee for the Supreme Court now I know
what you're thinking president Trump
hasn't nominated anybody for the Supreme
Court so how did he do that well he just
he just said that he had and the
students not knowing anything about
anything it decided to give their
impressions of the person who does not
yet exist here is Kevin Phillips what's
your reaction to the justice that he
nominate today I'm honestly not
surprised by his choice but that's just
worse for us I just told a pic and I was
like like it's almost at a point where
you kind of expect that some it's not
gonna be what you want
he's quite you know extreme in his views
and I don't know if he would make the
Supreme Court very even I see it all
over the news that like he's he's like
starting a new wave of something
something very negative and I'm really
scared about what happen in the future
and what choices he'll make so what
reaction have you seen on social media
today after the news oh this is just a
reoccurring thing he keeps doing this
with different positions and just doing
that every Watts abusing his power to do
so do you feel like this pick is an
abuse of power basically yeah it's
entire cabinet and everyone who's chosen
has been the white supremacist Legion of
Doom and it's dangerous everyone who
looks like me you feel like this Supreme
Court nominee today kind of falls in
that same line Chris they should all
wear white hoods and burn crosses at the
Capitol because that's exactly that's
exactly the move that's what they're
going for put someone up there that is
so racist and is not practicing the
quality that we need to see it's again
it's insulting and it's he's not gonna
last I mean I'm not a fan of the pic
they're burning crosses as what they're
doing who know that this is a great
little video because I'm not surprised
at all of course that's the reaction
that's what the forget those students
that's what the left-wing press does
that's what adults in the Democrat Party
do that's what you're gonna see
regardless of who the nominee is
tomorrow and so she I hope is a racist
and assist and a sexist and of this and
a bigot naman I don't know anything a
batter they don't know anything more
than these kids know about the invisible
person but it's gonna be a great
opportunity to gather these leftist
tears and it's a good reminder by the
way that they have no idea what they're
talking about they have no clue they're
just spouting little catchphrases racist
sexist
byah blah blah blah blah when a lefty
calls you that just it's okay let it
roll off you it doesn't mean anything
they're not talking about you they're
talking about whatever fantasy is
bouncing around there they're echoey
imaginations just like in that video all
right we're running late that's our show
well I hope gonna have a good show
tomorrow once we decide who the Supreme
Court justices in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you